good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast the morning matzo this
week oh that's her oh yeah her hair yeah
it's a story today I know you have much
to say much too good for children and I
have much to say too
oh not as much as you I have some pros
and cons before we get into it cuz like
the only time we've ever really I don't
have the energy to get into it there's
been time we've ever like fought like on
this show was like when you were just
getting like a little mean about Taylor
Swift so all I'm gonna say is say what
you want but like just be nice okay for
sure I was being a little critical and I
collapsed time I respect the hell out of
her I just don't like her pink tips okay
that's fine you know it
she wore like this like checkered coat
last night and I didn't like it either
but like I just loved her and you know
what I guess I got to go get a checkered
coat I understand like if Olivia culpo
died her and pink I'd be like so no
honestly I've been feeling like the way
that you feel about Lala I can't is the
most similar because I have some
thoughts on like a it's from last
night's episode I'm like you're not
gonna like that okay well I might like
them okay what well I will talk about
the episode but just tell me now and she
was out of control at that meal like
acting like this wise old sage but like
you were [ __ ] going nuts
a week ago no and it's like if I were
James I wouldn't trust you because I
don't know if you're gonna be nice and
they had this conversation once before
he was excited to be friends again and
then she totally stood him up so like I
don't know agree with what she did there
but I was just loving watching her face
moves yeah no I know but like she's over
here like being like I was in that place
like yeah yesterday like I hate when
people act like holier than thou and
it's like [ __ ] like no I I don't even
think maybe she means she's in that
place like this season but I feel like
she meant in the past where like she was
down and out because no one wanted to be
friends with her yeah but I thought she
meant more like the drinking spiraling
perhaps perhaps okay but God need to
Vanderpump rules to go out to
Kardashians
I did we'll get into Kardashian select
hyped up Kardashians and like nothing
crazy
no nothing crazy happened but I just
thought it was like interesante big of
an animal no anyway it was insightful
and you know what was very insightful
then I can't believe they didn't edit
out and even when Ben heard it he was
like did you really just say that my
love how they put a subtitle she left
her bag on the plane and Chloe was like
Courtney you're back two kids whatever
someone got it right look at your slave
right so we'll talk about I said was
full of interesting factoids that merely
showed the dynamics of how they travel
first of all did they charter a
commercial plane okay I thought the same
thing because their first fight they
flew
Marshall I don't think you can find a
private jet for that amount of time 18
hours but then the second second and a
half hour point two and a half hour
plane when they pulled up it was like a
747 like it was a great place so I have
to believe that an airline of Bali sent
them plane and was part of like a
tourism playing right because now I like
to think about like who pays for those
trips like on Bravo trips it's all paid
for by the network but at the end of the
day it's like a house and commercial
flights not that crazy a lot of the
times like the hotel if they want the
promo they keep it for free yeah the
house was being promote so the house was
totally free like The Bachelor the
hotels are free I think on the you know
but I'm saying Kardashian specifically
you travel at a level of luxury that I
don't think like a network would afford
but I also think the Kardashians might
have got paid by Bali because I'm really
a great commercial it's a great
commercial for Bali now it's on my list
of places that our vacation places that
I would love to go I know but it's so
fast after the flight like they
shouldn't have put further from New York
or closer like is it six hours more or
six hours less I don't know I don't know
either because when you fly to Australia
to fly that light but like when you you
can fly from New York to China so I feel
like at a certain point it's all the
same it's like just in the world's
connect cuz it's round right it's like
whatever whatever well so we're gonna
recap Vanderpump rules Kardashians and
what people pay trying up so did we do
yesterday we did babies couples from
history yesterday oh my god yeah okay
honestly it was mad confusing cuz
apparently I know nothing about history
or famous couples so we went through
like a comprehensive list of all the
most famous couples throughout history
like historical couples TV couples movie
couples celebrity couples and like how
impactful they were and how impactful
they were obviously we can speak on the
celebrity couples but I actually found
the most interesting and informative
ones were the historical couples that we
didn't know much about but what about
the Shah who built the Taj Mahal for his
dead wife right or what about the
perhaps the most famous and historical
couple of them all Adam and Eve right no
they are the most famous and the most
historical let me throw up a little bit
Napoleon and Josephine Henry the
eighth's
the Carrie Bradshaw at all we were
trying there were some things that we
knew about these people we thought we
were right we weren't sure it turns out
we were right about everything for these
and the divorce and the Church of
England and Queen Victoria and her kids
on every throne well you should
basically just listen to the episode
patreon.com slash morning toast
it's a morning toast I'm like this show
it's not full of fake facts yeah it was
a really interesting kind of different
episode for us and then we recorded
another episode which will we will be
releasing this week today all about
beauty and I got to sit down with I
don't know if you guys know where she's
like a huge lifestyle blogger she has an
international fashion and luxury
lifestyle brand my name is Jackie O like
I'm not sure if you're familiar with her
I scored the interview right embrace my
inner Diane Sawyer we just like went for
it you know yeah I basically I've never
talked so much in my life one no more
importantly yet I've never talked so
little right because I think I spilled
some interesting factoids that we're
well interesting about just my life
experience and how I got to be the woman
I am today which is hardly a woman but
before all that we would be remiss if we
didn't deliver the Fast Five story is
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast okay you've held your tongue long
enough till reps out with new pink dip
dyed hair is it another cue fresh music
is on the way Taylor Swift is creating a
pink sister once again people and you
know what I originally had the article
from Ian like sometimes I don't read the
article before I read it on the show and
I was reading it and they were just
taking way too many creatively okay
People magazine was more straight facts
I appreciate you taking a creative
Liberty and mixing and the E news
article mixing he News's creative
liberties and thank you for not making
fun of the way I just couldn't say
shaking okay on Monday the delicate
singer stepped out of New York City
rocking pink dip dyed hair Swift
complimented her tresses by wearing a
pink long-sleeved cropped t-shirt which
fans believe his new merch because the
sleeves say Taylor Swift oh oh no it's
100% new merch I didn't see that a case
sad Taylor sweat it was really I'm up
and down the arm it's very it's a white
shirt and it says Taylor Swift in white
how do you see that it's easy to miss
there's more pictures oh my back okay
and also a lot of people are thinking
that it's a cropped shirt and she
basically corrupted herself because the
name of the album is underneath like
where she cropped but she cut herself oh
that is a good theory I guess we'll see
you in a year like when we're at tour
like what the merch is yeah it could
just be a crop shirt cuz it's silly cute
shirt she paired the top with pink and
green floral shorts and Gucci sneakers
that she borrowed from bed and saw her
the Grammy winner also wore fuchsia pink
lipstick okay so we're definitely have a
pink vibe which I
I totally she was in town because
tomorrow shoes
today it's today the 23rd yet she's
performing at the time 100 like I don't
even know what she's gonna perform like
I don't care
and so she's staying on her house and
try back up with Chuck I just really
want to go and like stand outside for
but like I feel like my feet will hurt
this she'll take so long to come out and
I got like a 10-second picture and also
like you really shouldn't wait outside
celebrities homes it's a huge basin
privacy but also she was in town for two
geodude's birthday last night as well
yes when she stepped out wearing like a
really ugly coat but obviously now I
have to buy it realizing it was a denim
themed party everyone was wearing denim
Olivia culpo
looked phenomenal killer was wearing
denim her coat must have been it wasn't
gonna it must have been everyone was
wearing denim I just posted a picture on
my selfie Anam seemed but everyone was
wearing Genie vibes okay
maybe was Genie bags only themed maybe
um back to Taylor Swift I can't remember
had a dream last night or if I was
thinking about in the car and I forgot
to write it down but I had an idea for
what hurt her sob um like what the name
would be though because there was a
someone she posted a picture of a
briefcase every year like businesswomen
special and now I it maybe this wasn't
as good as I thought it was at me but I
thought maybe the title could be like
back to business that's horrible
just watch can you imagine well here's
the fact so it's here's a new piece
okay the briefcase is obviously like a
still from set like you know did you
ever see the babe music video she's like
working in an office and her husband's
cheating on her something like it was
very like Mad Men vibes okay so it's
obviously just a part of the aesthetic
of the music video whatever the song's
about whatever the music video is about
there's a woman with a briefcase and
that's pretty much all I know but more
importantly I think why that that's not
an accurate title is because the whole
message and what I firmly believe to be
the truth is that this album was
supposed to be the album before a
reputation she was like about to release
it but Kim and Kanye like ruined her
life and then she like hid in a hole and
wrote a whole other album that she
thought was more important to release
first agree because there's a huge gap
in the songs like there are no songs
really about Calvin Harris and like that
time in her life uh-huh but she's on top
of the world she was blue chela like she
was at the Met Gala like there was
really there's no albums no Tom
Hiddleston right except getaway car is
the only song about Tom Hiddleston Met
Gala and Calvin Harris whatever so
there's a like a time period of her life
that's missing from 1989 til reputation
because she took so much time off so I
believe she had
these songs written for like ts6 but now
we've had to put them on hold and now
it's gonna be TS 7 and it's and it's
even better because now she's like
branding it as like this happy-go-lucky
like step into the daylight kind of
moment where this reputation was like
this dark leather like snakeskin vibe
which was good for what it was but I'm
very much happy to be moving on to like
a brighter more like butterfly themed
moment I have to disagree I don't think
it's gonna be those songs I think those
songs will never see the light of day
and unless like she has a museum about
herself one day because I think as an
artiste
it wouldn't be ascending to be singing
like she's always singing about her like
current or recent past and so to be
singing about things that happened three
years ago and to be putting on that
persona like that album was supposed to
be happy pink young fresh on top of the
world and that's not what happened to
her so I well that's what that's why she
didn't release the album in that moment
understood but I think maybe the album
she's releasing now is like the post
reputation okay so she emerged from the
ashes like a rose like a phoenix well so
I don't
that was reputation and now she's a
bunny maybe but I don't necessarily
agree with the fact that she only writes
songs about current history because
there are songs on on reputation that
you could argue our about John Mayer Oh
totally I like it's not about the I feel
like she writes songs like over the
course of her life and then just picks
them for the album's like I feel like
she's like 300 songs that like maybe
might make it a mate not cuz she's
always doing like bonus tracks like the
best I think some of Taylor's best songs
were bonus tracks on 1989 they only got
a few about the album at Target
yeah you know then she just has this
cachet of music like and it's not in
coming upon a schedule you know or like
a time period I don't know I would love
to hear that album is this is that album
I would be excited but I it was such a
good time for the problem is that it
wouldn't show growth right it would show
that she hiccup
she went through it and now she's back
to the person she was who by the way did
lie about what was said on that phone
call oh my god by the way person that
she was it sound like she was a terrible
if she was she was being out of control
you know oh my gosh you got me a donut
at the height of everything she was
being a control and like she with her
girl squad she admits that now when she
admitted she was in and she was reformed
she was being annoying but she got ahead
of herself because she was bullying in
high school like right I don't take
anything that she did before like like
Kim did it fixed Taylor wow they just
they schooled her because she was being
like a little bit she was being a little
petty she was being a little annoying so
you're saying the album that would be
coming out on Friday is the album of
that annoying girl yeah who cares it's
still good music I don't know and it's
like a just she what she liked was being
annoying it's like what ariana grande is
doing now so it's like an ariana grande
doesn't it's like oh my god she's so
amazing like when Taylor does it she's
annoying a petty I can't wait what is
ariana grande doing just like writing
songs about everyone that she knows like
her exes yeah that's what Taylor Swift's
new doing loves when she wrote about her
exes yeah it was soon saying the person
that she was what she's not writing
about no girl getting got on stage and
said when someone tries to take credit
for your fame as if she didn't know that
that song was coming out and that she
approved that lyric I'm just saying like
you're acting like she's like a better
person now cuz like she murdered someone
and she went to prison and now she's
like reforms like she wasn't a bad
person back then I like the album that
she created doesn't need to be trashed
because she went through like a public
whatever I just think she's grown and
it's true I think the songs are still
good and they deserve to be heard okay
I'm here for it that was like as much as
she was like annoying back then like I
lived for that Taylor like the 1989
Taylor like she was so cute so glam like
I loved all of her outfits like
everything she wore was so cute I'm like
yes he was ignoring Blake it was cool to
choose hang out with Selena Gomez like
everyone died when she had that 4th of
July party at her house and even like
the I heart ts like time I don't
something like I was here for it like he
was annoying but I live for it so I
definitely want to hear an album from
that moment cuz like mine when she was
so normal just like going to Vegas like
when her boyfriend was DJing at at
excess and like she was just like a girl
in Vegas with her friends yes so normal
when her boyfriend was going to a
massage parlor
oh my god please everyone goes to
massage parlor Robert Kraft like please
like everyone everyone can do everything
they want but when Taylor Smith does it
it's not okay like I can't I need
Margaux here listen I really I really
love her I love her music but she's just
had a different level and I'm holding
her to that standard okay but that
doesn't mean that music that she's
written in different stages of her life
doesn't deserve to be heard no but her
whole thing has always been like her
music reflects who she is what she's
going through that way and I think now
she's been through and he's a I agree
this then she was three years ago and I
want to hear from this person did that I
agree with that I agree with being like
saying that her album always reflects
the current state that she's in and to
release an album from two years ago
would just be counterproductive so that
I will agree with you on but I do feel
like those songs were like in a really
good place in her life and I would like
to hear it I completely agree like she
became the person that the
sixteen-year-old in her always wanted to
be and as much as it was annoying like
she is definitely delayed in her growth
like she's a 30 year old walking around
with pink streaks in her butt like she
was 15 and like didn't finish high
school and like was on tour like the
first only female to like sell out
arenas like she's definitely stunted in
her growth a little bit so when she was
26 acting like a 21 year old like
running around town with her girlfriends
like being the cool girl like it was
annoying for sure but like that's just
the way that her life turned out to be
uh you know what I was actually really
happy for her because it's not often
that you get to be the person that you
wanted to be in this world
ya wanted to be in high school got
bullied by in high school yeah and now
you get to be the bully and good for you
ya know to enjoy and then it tasted even
bigger person to recognize like you
became that person and you didn't want
to be I agree so for her to release
music by that person I just don't
associate the person with the music
because I feel like she's has this
catalog of music that like I babe
totally serious you will like five years
ago
I totally agree until reputation yes
because that was so like moment driven
yeah timely for sure okay okay so great
we're good we're in a good place
everyone don't worry we'll be okay maybe
no we'll be okay like I just like honest
like I [ __ ] hate talking about Taylor
with you like you just like because you
know making valid points but like I just
I prefer to live in a rose-colored world
where like Taylor Swift is end-all
be-all and like well here's the thing
she's she's making a rose-color and so
here for it I just like I prefer to talk
to Margaret I was talking about Taylor
she's like we both love her but I don't
like I don't know Riley I don't love her
but right and I admittedly left her
blind date blindly and I'm like I'm not
gonna be out here in common section like
trying to make a point was like you
might have a better point than me but at
the end of the day like I love Taylor
Swift so much like I feel like I learned
from her and I just like choose to see
her in only positive way that's how I
feel about Kim and la Lala but I don't
know like Lala we've had a short
relationship so far I only get to see
her like 10 minutes a week I feel that
way about Kim also I feel away that came
no matter what Kim does I will find a
way to rationalize it yeah me too I
think yeah like I mostly I refuse to
speak ill of Taylor Swift because like I
really want to get noticed by her I'm
like if I'm out here talking [ __ ] like
Taylor nation is not
hook me up you know with reputation room
tickets that's true but no I think where
we stand tailor [ __ ] okay some really
exciting news that crossed my desk this
morning and I hadn't seen it anywhere
else okay
Scott Disick lands NUI show flipping and
remodeling high-end homes and flip it
like Disick oh my god so many thoughts
one such a good name - what a missed
opportunity for Kourtney like she could
tell the interiors of these homes she's
so dumb this was an idea six years ago
that she shoved out because she didn't
want to do more TV yeah finally he's
become a big star in his own right that
they have decided that he can carry this
show can we talk about Kardashians now
just because it's pertinent sure and I
was just like so shook this episode by
the growth of one Scott Disick and how
everyone was talking about him like what
I just found an interesting factoid in
this article was fueled by his passion
for property development Disick is
teaming up with former pop singer turned
interior designer Williford
I want to be bad make that look so good
I feel like I really learned about like
what sex was like from that music video
of Williford but she's wearing those
tiny tiny tiny shorts like basically
under and all the girls wearing them too
and just mangu I'm about to break the
rules I wanna be I wanna be bad baby ah
give me that music video and the Candy
Man team or music video related music
videos that really like change lives and
shaped me as a woman
understood also she's Kaitlin Cooper she
will afford is Kaitlin Cooper shut the
[ __ ] up
Marissa Cooper's little sister's gonna
fact-check that but yeah Willa Ford is
not Kaitlin Cooper that's a different
Willa then oh okay or what wait hold on
now I have twenties will afford she's I
want to be bad no she anyone else oh I
don't think she was ever an actress come
on Cooper Willa Holland Wow apparently
there's two Willa's and then what are
the odds two iconic willows okay I don't
feel so stupid for saying that well I
just wanna go back to very interesting
factoids thank you for sharing but I
would like to jump into the Kardashians
episode because I was really shook up by
Scott like being such a good dad like
and I love how they all talk about him
like went behind his back being like
wait he's like so no I'm honest being
such a good dad and it's like for
someone who has made her
career and like it's constantly putting
herself on a pedestal in terms of
parenting I was really shocked by
Courtney this episode like and I'm not a
parent so I don't know what it's like to
travel with three kids and I'm sure it's
really hard but I'm pretty sure like you
wait for them to fall asleep before you
do right right and like she definitely
had to take a sleeping pill because 15
hours on a plane right with kids
screaming and like good for you I can I
have one but you like your kids are just
running amok I mean I guess when there's
so many so many crew members members and
then a man he's like she doesn't have to
worry but why did it all fall on clothes
Chloe and like again like I I can't
speak to anything because I'm not a
parent but like her kids are wild like
they were so loud on the plane yeah
that's a tough age and they said they
all are like there are so many cousins
around the same age and it's like a
really tough intense Asian they just
bring out like the craziness on each
other but yet why it all fell on Cortney
is
I mean Chloe's beyond me I guess because
Kim truly has her hands full she also
has three kids Scott is doing what he
can as as a dad yeah and Chloe's just
there and Chloe's always been the one to
like help because she didn't was the one
for so long who didn't have kids like
her priorities have changed yeah like
when she gets the house under packs
aren't there I was like I understand no
I told her then why didn't everyone's
ask for 22 hours where's my [ __ ] bag
and Kourtney just in the way that she
speaks she's so rude yeah so dismissive
and condescending and like I don't know
how someone has a conversation with her
because it's like she just said she's
like Lisa Vanderpump she'll like say a
jab and then expect the conversation to
go on as normal and when someone holds
her accountable for their jabs she just
like sits there and laughs and it's so
annoying but she doesn't even she's
actually worse and Lisa Vanderpump cuz
at least at least I've ever pom hides
behind the fact that she's joking
I just wish Kourtney's just like no
that's the truth garyun no she was
pissing me off so much and Chloe
definitely overreacted like in the
moment but you know it's like build-up
like it's not the one thing that that
upsets you the most it's like the the
week lead-up yeah I actually didn't even
think that she overreacted because it
was so warranted yeah and she walked
away yeah which is the thing you can she
could have hurled insults lepton like
when Courtney was complaining about the
six lip glosses in her in her pouch that
was so everything she was like trying to
say was so crazy and her bag I'm like I
have that I did you know how many
[ __ ] lip sticks I have in this bag
right here I'll see your sisters own
cosmetics companies like yeah you're
gonna have a lot of lip liners and your
famous like you wear makeup like it was
the fact that her assistant was now
probably like fired the
she didn't organize her pouches enough
she said I have my my this is what she
said I have my assistants label make an
inventory list of what's in every single
one of my pouches that you have too much
money too much assistance yeah like are
you kidding me that was so crazy like
and then other than that I just like
enjoyed watching the episode like them
doing vacationing like Kim taking all
the kids for the day to the Chocolate
Factory like Kim is a saying she is sane
yeah and when she said st. was her
favorite now I like I know she said
thanks her favorite um I like I'm
watching it through that lines like
saying it's totally her favorite like
she was having is holding his hand the
whole episode I I've never even seen
that I didn't I guess I missed it saying
what do you think what she does ha go
there yeah who's her cutest kid it's
it's impossible to say because each one
is cuter than the next I think say and
like for say looks almost like ha me I I
just love North because we get the most
out of her as a as a kid whoa whoa whoa
and I think Chicago is like the most
beautiful baby
no Chicago's beautiful I I can't recall
this boy or girl
no but when they were talking about rain
and they were like rain he's crazy I was
like what I know I can't ever remember
if rain is a boy or girl or Chicago's
boy or girl because their boats rain is
more of a masculine name so I guess I
understand that but Chicago is a girl
I think Chicago's a girl and rain keeps
his hair really long so and he's
beautiful and has the same face as
Penelope he's beautiful so I always at
first think he's a girl these have some
gendered fluid children Mason is huge
oh my god he is like Scott's ya know
like they're growing out go to get beers
yeah soon soon like honestly when he
turns 14 probably that'll be so
interesting like if if they continue the
show until 8 a Mason being an adult like
wow they probably will and then I want
the hills with Mason and his friends
yeah Mason his tents like that's only
eight more years of shows yeah until
he's a legit guy I'm so crazy until he's
Sophia's age the show has won Sophia on
vacation uh completely also I also
caught up on two weeks ago because I
didn't watch I like the way that
Kourtney was like like what sort like
you lords or learn or something I'll
hurt someone's head yeah like Scott like
if you want to come to the trip you have
to do this like it's like please they
wanted Scott there more than they wanted
you you see up Kim's face lit up when
she said that Scott was coming like
they and Chloe too like they all wanted
to hang out with him the way that she
just like makes him work for everything
and she was like I don't want to give
you mixed messages and he was like I'm
in a full relationship like you're not
like I'm good right I'm so glad he said
that she's really out of control
she's out of control and I'm so happy
for Scott and it's clear like this
people are like he's the best he's ever
been and they're all saying like he's
such a great dad he's so positive like
he's so hands-on and lest we not forget
like who was probably responsible for a
lot of that change Sophie i.t she
deserves credit the effort giving us
like our Scott back yeah you know and
it's sad that Kourtney and Scott didn't
work out but like now I'm at the point
where it's like I hope Scott never gets
back together with Kourtney and I hope
she lives to entice and adore her life
those were some dark terrible she was so
mean to him she was so mean to him he
was so terrible they were a horrible
couple yeah but you know it all worked
out they have beautiful children and
then co-parent nicely but I also hope
they never get back together ya know
like for his sake
yeah she's so mean okay are you ready
for the next story we don't want to go
back to that uh to the flipping houses
yes it's gonna be on a it's gonna be on
II an eight-episode one-hour series will
premiere this summer it's actually crazy
how long TV takes to to get off the
ground because obviously Scott's been
thinking about this for like five years
mm-hmm and I really feel like in their
heyday like this would have been great
for them even though I don't want to see
corneum or on TV but like this is what
they were like meant to do it's like
everyone found their niche in the
Kardashians like outside of the show
like Kylie femme cosmetics Kim found
cosmetics everyone found like their own
thing Chloe with the jeans Kendall with
the modeling Kendall with modeling and
it like Kourtney never found her thing
it's cause like she found it and like
wouldn't pursue it yeah and I was
pursuing with Williford
he said I'm excited to bring fans a new
series that shows what I'm really
passionate about professionally which is
flipping real estate and doing crazy and
impressive renovations on celebrity
homes he has never had a show like this
before it's a bit different than viewers
are used to seeing that I think they
will be both entertained and inspired by
my team depending on Willa for it's like
vibe I will 100% be watching this I mean
I love a house living show his best
friend and business partner
Benny Luciani Luciano will be in it and
their contractor Mikey Moore and his
assistant Lindsey diamond know I'm so
here for it yeah totally I'm still here
for it I'm so here for it I'll be
watching let's have a watch party no
totally I'm just so happy for Scott he's
also like an investor and that
talentless yeah which is like fancy
sweatpants yeah and they were included
on all those giveaways that the
Kardashians I've been doing like body oh
right oh right honestly it looks pretty
cozy but I just can't get my head around
spending that much money on pajamas no
but I for like when I'm traveling it
would be nice but then it becomes [ __ ]
totally ok that's what you just need
bombas I love Matt Damas I've been like
really like taking like note of my socks
recently ever since our since I started
wearing Obamas it just highlights like
the shitty quality of other socks
because how often do you think about
your socks if you're like I used to be
not much but I recently discovered socks
that changed the way that I think about
socks forever and they're called bombas
mama's are the most comfortable socks in
the history of feet it's true they're
made from super soft natural cotton and
every pair comes with an arch support
seamless toe and a cushioned footbed
that's comfortable but not too thick
with different colors patterns lainson
style bomba so great in the gym at the
office or out on the town by your
bombers at bombas comm slash toast today
and get 20% off your first purchase
that's Bo MBA s.com slash toast for 20%
off Bo MBA Escom slash toast trust me
it's worth it totally your feet deserve
a break my feet you deserve it
pizzas are bombas my feet deserve the
world okay our next three stories are in
our well-rounded segment right because
they're all quite interesting mmm first
up have you seen this Instagram has
considered hiding the light count on
people's photos I heard that they were
hiding the follower count on people's
profile also coming next - so Instagram
that's it hiding like horrible are you
photos so audiences can't see how many
people have liked an individual post an
unreleased feature that would publicly
hide the light counts was spotted by
code hunter Jane Wong who says the test
states that Instagram wants your
followers to focus on what you share not
how many likes your post get only the
person who posted a photo will be able
to see the number of likes it received
Instagram says that it has not tested
the feature in a statement to the verge
and Instagram hoax spokesperson said
what we're not testing this at the
moment but exploring ways to reduce
pressure on Instagram is something we're
always thinking about okay I absolutely
hate this idea unless it's something you
can choose like you know how people like
Taylor Swift has no comments ever like
we're from select people then now
there's like one
you comment so I'm like gigi hadid could
comment if she wanted and that's how
like Drake has it too if it's an option
that like you can put on voluntarily I'm
cool with that but if they make the
entire platform like ever no button has
a choice and there's no more likes
anymore like I'll be pissed
well I hate the idea of no more
followers it's like I haven't been
working this hard thirsting for this
many years for it all to go away so that
I don't agree with I do think the idea
of not of not everyone being able to see
your likes is interesting it definitely
relieves pressure I think people would
then post more which is what Instagram
always wants and like it would be nice
to post and really not have to worry
about what the likes are and only you
would see them so you wouldn't know if
you're still posting garbage I think
it's an interesting
I'm so glad here I'm not gonna be like
on the front lines like championing it
but I I don't mind it I really don't I
just hate when like things are working
great and then like Mark Zuckerberg is
out here trying to change them you know
yes and I always feel that way but then
there are so many updates that have
happened where at the time I'm like this
is terrible and now in hindsight it's
like there this was the way to remember
in high school would be perfect and then
they change their thing and there used
to be like ways to like go back yeah
well there you used to not have a news
like I can't imagine using Facebook the
way that we used to now like it wouldn't
be able to be the platform that it is
now without those changes and there are
still some changes that they do that I
hate like really none of us need
Facebook stories totally like please
make it stop
but like when Instagram stories came and
we're like man if I'm fat cat yeah now
it's changed everything that's true so I
think some change is necessary um and I
don't know I don't hate this idea I
think people would post more and just be
more candid I know that I would I would
love it if it were optional but how
could it be optional
like you're going through you're feeding
you see some people have likes and other
people don't thinking just assume that
person got no likes no you just assume
that they decided to turn that feature
on I don't know I think it this is an
all or not this isn't like comments I'm
gonna they'll be so crazy that would
like really shake up the Instagram like
world like platform forever yeah except
I do like seeing how many likes other
people get I don't know like who's fake
yeah I'm just saying for me like
sometimes I won't post something because
I'm like even though I'd like this
Kjartan Oh photo do well think about
some of the bloggers that were obsessed
with
because they have like the fakest
accounts everyone 300,000 powers that
they bought and 2000 likes yeah likes
doesn't make sense we couldn't like what
would I do on my fence - all day no
that's true it should be like uh video
views like it's not oh my god there is
oh I agree with that it's not on the
newsfeed but you could click on
someone's post and see how many likes
that they did get but it's not super a
bad read prevalent I think that would be
cool there is a toaster subgroup about
like toasters who are obsessed with
bloggers I think I told you about this
and I joined these just cause like I
love to keep up with fellow bloggers you
know and they have got me hooked on this
girl I'm like I can't say her name but
like I want to die like they're fully
convinced that she's she's pregnant
therefore they convinced she has a fake
belly and like honestly I kind of look
great like they're so crazy I've never
heard of this girl in my life like and
she's just not my like cup of tea no no
I'm just not her target Am I
yeah like she just lived a totally
different life than me but like I look
at her Instagram everyday now because
like I'm 100% she'll be in a romper and
like having no belly should put on a
dress she's not much pregnant it's the
craziest thing that is crazy no I think
if someone's taking a pregnancy and
they're on social media it almost thinks
do you think that she is really pregnant
it just is weird because she would do a
better job like why would she put on
that romper without right fake that's
true like it looks so fake like it has
to be real right and it's like all she
does is probably social media holiday
like I'm sure she's aware so it must be
people are commenting it so it must has
she posted like any like bathing suit
pictures with one-pieces no she won't
show her belly it's always showing the
realities she wear to pieces before I
didn't I started following her like two
weeks ago I don't have my own thin stuff
well you have gotten to get one there
has been a few situations where I've
needed one I mean one girl that I'm
obsessed with that Olivia got me
obsessed with and I got you obsessed
with and obsessive and I should follow
Jackie I said the same thing I've
started she deserves a nice night
following her as a hate follow and I'm
obsessed with her now like I buy all of
her stuff like I can't every time she
post I'm like waiting with bated breath
like she's just this billionaire who has
like no sense of what the real world is
and like has the most beautiful clothes
and it's like always swiping up so like
$6,000 jackets but like I love her and
some of the stuff she does is like so
cringy and horrible like it makes me
want to die but like I love her and like
I'm getting her so many views for my pin
so like I should just follow her know
and that's that's how I feel like if I'm
checking all the time on someone they
deserve my follow they're doing
something worth following right I mean
there's another girl she's like a
fitness like health enthusiast and like
when she talks into the camera like I
feel like taking my phone and like
literally having it run over by a Mack
truck like an 18-wheeler yes you do and
she is horrible I'm like like just like
always putting together a GTV he's like
I can't I can't okay but so I was saying
like I feel like if I get a fit instead
like it's just a it's it's not a good
road to be on if there's someone who I'm
so interested in that I need to check up
on them all the time like they deserve a
follow no you know what there's someone
that I can't be seen right following so
a lot of people will DME stories like
you should see this or this person
mentioned you so I'm not ever gonna like
look at this like low level like
whatever on my I don't want them to see
that girl's on job watch so I will go on
my fence and go to that person's story
and like see what they're saying about
me cuz if it's bad I don't want them to
know that like they said something bad
about me like there's this girl oh my
god this girl who it was so funny
because I had heard of her username
before and was because she dm's me 1000
times over the past few years like being
thirsty as hell like can you post this
and then she'd put something nasty at me
in her story and I was like [ __ ] are
you fretting Katie but I'd want her to
see that I saw so I took out my fence
down look oh that that's the only reason
for a fence so like if you're someone
who like is trying to look at a guy your
ex your exes girlfriend all that finster
material but if it's to stalk bloggers
who are clearly interesting enough to
check out all the time I think they
deserve your follow and if people are
doing it to me
follow me know it's like the pregnant
girl like I'm definitely not gonna
follow but the girl who like I've been
hate following for years that has slowly
turned into an absolutely like love and
adore follow I think I want to follow
her I think she deserves it and I wonder
it was possible she someone will figure
like this I'm gonna hold off on
following her breath um wait I want to
say one more thing about I look at I
actually met her once
oh speaking of people talking about you
on their stories in the episode the
patient up stood they were posting today
I finally figure out what Claudius cross
to bear in life is and you have to
listen to it because I just I really
feel for you my sister thank you and you
saw that firsthand
I saw it firsthand and
in hand because uh right that Instagram
story that was just like so weird okay
okay what was the sort of Instagram oh
very interesting thank you for sharing
of course like any story about Instagram
just has me talking about my favorite
bloggers to hate right well welcome to
see you followed like that you like well
I don't ever like go to anyone's blog so
people that have blogs said I follow
well you know we met those girls Adam in
Nashville know at revolve oh my god what
was her name she's gorgeous and Sophie
they're these four girls who were just
like the best-dressed girls at Riv
office we wanted looking at them before
we started talking to them we were
looking at this girl the girl in the
pink was her name Emma and we were like
holy [ __ ] that is the cutest outfit and
that girl is the most beautiful and
obviously she ended up being a toaster
because all toasters are beautiful and
her whole all of her friends were
toasters and their awesome channel dying
and they like take pictures together
they like Jess they just have great flow
they taught me about pfg which is pink
feed goals cuz they're obsessed with the
flow as well yeah and I started
following them and like my life has
changed no they were really cool like
that's what's supposed to happen at
revolve you know yeah no they were just
a great representation of the culture
and like the Coachella and revolve yeah
and it was just nice to meet them and
just like what it means to be like
beautiful like on the inside Anna and a
toaster right the fact that they ended
up being toasters is like what made it
was so that's how we knew they were
beautiful on the inside
yeah they also had straight teeth so I
was like wanting to kiss them right
I just love must you've used candid cuff
they must have because candid is helping
people gain confidence through
accessible and affordable orthodontic
care candid makes the process of
straightening your teeth convenient and
easy by having the customer take the
process into their own hands straighter
and brighter teeth in an average of six
months and cost sixty five percent less
than braces everything is delivered to
your home White Glove customer service
in addition to email and phone support
candid we'll set up a video call with
you to answer any questions you have and
talk through any modeling process Kenda
makes clear liners that are sent
directly to your home and are customized
specifically for you to straighten your
teeth you're one step away from getting
straighter whiter teeth take advantage
of candids risk-free schraeder kits
guarantee plus when you use our
dedicated link canted co.com slash toast
you'll save 50% off on your starter kit
that's kenneth cocom slash toast to get
50% off of your first starter kit candid
co.com
slash toast nice
it's good stuff what's another
well-rounded story we got today okay
this is I'm excited to get your thoughts
on this but you know don't yak anyone's
youngin ever Washington State is set to
be the first state to allow quote human
composting so you can be buried you can
have be cremated and soon you can have
your dead body composted what's the
opposite when someone you like people do
it with like garbage or like fruit or
dead animals apparently where you let it
like sort of decompose and you use it
for like fertilizer in soil that's nice
I feel like there are some people who
look they are that so much that they
would want that it's what they have it
computes it's like you always have to
leave your food oh yeah host well like I
mean this is not for me but I do really
like understand the concept of like not
being attached to like your physical
body once they're dead like there's
nothing there and not wanting to be
buried yeah and it's like coffin season
is so horrible so scary and like and you
get to give back to the minute our dad
died what ten years ago and I've been to
visit him once
I just feel no connection to like the
physical place of a sense of the burial
and I find them to be like creepy and
weird and so if there's something you
can do like organ donors are that makes
the most sense like and also like we you
are buried because you know we're made
from the dust and we're going back to
the dust but if you're being composting
you are still returning to the dust I
mean I guess there's just something
weird about like sitting in a field like
with dead bodies like technically in it
like in like dead like the vibes yeah
but like spooky vibes for sure but you
know what like the more I think about it
like the more we should be doing like
better things with dead bodies because
like I feel maybe I'm unique like I
think maybe other people like feel
really like connected to grave burial
spots but like I just think like there's
no connection between like the way you
feel about someone and like their memory
and like the physical resting place of
their body no but it's like if you do go
visit it it forces you to like confront
your feelings and and that's true you
know so it's a it's good for that but
like people who like have a huge like
you can always tell like where there's
like a real like flamboyant like it's
flowing there might really show off you
like a person
Liam yeah with like the huge greatest
ever like a bench there stuntin on this
cemetery honestly you're an ass like
don't waste money give it to the poor
agreed
Washington appears set to become the
first state to allow a burial
alternative known as quote natural
organic reduction an accelerated
decomposition process that turns bodies
into soil within weeks the bill
legalizing the process sometimes
referred to as quote human composting
has passed the legislature and is headed
back and is headed to the desk of
democratic governor jay Inslee if signed
by the governor the new law would take
effect on May 1st 2020 in Slee
spokeswoman Jamie Smith said that while
the governor's office is still reviewing
the bill this seems like a thoughtful
effort to soften our footprint on the
earth I don't you know I'm planning
Sherry's for you know this part of town
and while I'm excited I just won't be
sitting on any fields writing like you
also just don't wanna then now they'll
start like harvesting bodies for compost
so so it's like once they cremate you
what they'd like to put it in the earth
or but if they put it in dirt you don't
get cremated you like decompose those
actual body yeah oh I thought you meant
like the ashes no the body
oh he composes within weeks and then you
are able to be used as fertilizer what
about the bones - bones decompose I know
so what do you do at the bones I don't
know maybe you bury those or I don't
know anything that's like it's a weird
thing to think about cuz like once here
no longer on this earth like you don't
necessarily need to occupy like space
you know yeah no I know I don't think
it's like so crazy no I mean um and it's
like people donate their organs this is
a way to give back to them yeah like I
think and I don't want to offend anyone
but like I think cremating is like weird
you know it's like you're burning your
body like our people just escaped that
you know right now like there's only two
options be buried or be cremated and
like some people don't want to be
married I would rather you know what I
would rather be and they just I was
watching Game of Thrones and this is
what they do in the Iron Islands they
ship you like off to sea and they let
your body like the fish like eat your
body I wouldn't want that either it's
like now I could feed like other species
you can if you become Hugh
compost who am i feeding fertilizer it
helps grow fruits vegetables it's good
for the animals is good for the frosting
why they use horse [ __ ] as fertilizer
they do mm-hmm the were the worth it's
weird it's an interesting place this is
really what one man [ __ ] is another
man's treasure it's true mm-hmm well
this is interesting I'd be I'd be
curious to see the first person to do it
you know yeah and if it goes through
we'll definitely keep you posted
interesting story thank you for sharing
you're welcome I get this newsletter
that I just have to shout out where I
get a lot of my interesting stories it's
called me to know it's the only news
letter subscription that I subscribe to
and I just can't recommend it enough
they really should you're sort of
interesting factoids did you ever see
the episode of my what is it called like
oh [ __ ] it's like that TLC show like my
crazy oh my strange addiction my strange
addiction where the girl was addicted to
eating her like dad's or her husband's
ashes right that was disgusting
discussing that turned me off to
cremating right okay I understand why
you're averse to it
yeah thism final story in some crazy
black mirror [ __ ] British company wants
to discreetly weigh passengers before
each flight I'm gonna say that again
Brit I knew you like I'm not going to
London anytime soon British company
wants to discreetly weigh passengers
before each flight to reduce costs a
British tech startup wants to figure out
more accurate ways of weighing
passengers ahead of flights
although most passengers are accustomed
to weighing their bags before takeoff
the calculations don't actually stop
their airline crews have to
approximately determine the total amount
of weight on board each flight before
takeoff in order to ensure that there
will be enough people to make the
journey the ollie report in the
treacherous jaren sea wave the heavier
the plane the more fuel required I
didn't realize that they weighed your
bags like for that purpose but I guess
that makes sense if you're bringing a
ton of bricks yeah
however since passengers aren't required
to step on a scale themselves airlines
aren't really able to get an exact
number which means planes often carry
more fuel than necessary which doesn't
like seem like a bad thing what if we
get we added what if there's a divine
diversion right you know both the
airlines costs and its carbon footprint
okay well the carbon footprint I think
I understand but like but what if I
decide to human compost can I get a pass
right yeah we give beginning we take
yeah quote it's critical to oh that was
also something about Scott when he was
like I think it's symbolic that instead
of taking the charge was from the island
he left treasures instead and he was
like I think it's symbolic that I'm
giving instead of taking genius it's
critical to know the actual weight and
to ensure the correct fuel uplift the
company's CEO told Lonely Planet
according to the Washington Post most
airlines rely on generous estimations
for the weight of its passengers 197
pounds for men 154 pounds for women and
77 pounds for children so I guess yeah
that's an accurate no but that would be
the app that's what they're averaging
but some people are more some people are
less right
but even so that's not the average wait
I believe so they're estimating up well
instead of having people wait like
getting weighed on planes why do they
have every person just stay there wait
yeah we're like a range because
obviously you know no one wants to know
if airports aren't and I'm not really
that way like nobody knows for sure you
know it's like are they gonna let me
take my shoes off right it's like this
is it the middle of the day is it before
breakfast right big difference am I
wearing a hoodie or a t-shirt right and
then everyone's gonna start like tossing
lightly will he be even more naked and
gross I gotta totally know I mean I
understand like the physics behind this
but like to have a scale on board is
just not an option no I think you should
be able like right with your or they
mean this is also her this is just a
sounding so black mirror but maybe like
when you go get your like TSA number you
know how everyone has like a redress
number yeah when you do that they weigh
you and it's part of your like profile
like you know you're just like your age
and your sex it's like go with it it's
part of your profile right when you
check when you book flight I struggle
with this because like a weight is like
it's not like it's just a number like in
its facts like you're stepping out right
it's your height right and so but
there's some things I don't know like so
deeply personal about it that like I
mean there's like one joke in my show
about like a weight like a number and
every time I say it like I have the
biggest fan of my stomach I can't
believe I just told people how much I
used to weigh you know any mean ya know
there's something deeply personal about
it but if you take that out of it
this isn't like
such a I don't think we should be
weighing in likes at camp at the at the
airport right but I understand the you
know this thought behind and understand
the mechanics behind it like why we need
to do it but I just think it's a
slippery slope because then from here
maybe we go into black Mara where where
you do get rated based on how you are as
a passenger you think that's something
airlines need to know - totally maybe
you can't sit in first class if you're
an [ __ ]
that should be allowed nobody but it
shouldn't being an [ __ ] is your right
I agree your god-given right you paid
you paid for this ticket just to be an
[ __ ] right and whatever do what you
wanna do or you could sleep 15 hours and
let your kids run amok someone just oh
and it's according to Ramona Singer like
this is something we need to know
because the average my role is huge yeah
she's so funny
but know that I guess this is like a
British thing but like it's probably
more of an issue in America because
America does have a problem with obesity
so I guess weight distribution is even
harder and I guess starting in in
Britain is like less touchy because they
don't you know cuz they did it first and
they don't feel some type of way about
their weight right there
they don't have an obesity problem no so
it's like just getting someone's height
I don't know this would be so crazy but
I think there's there's a tasteful way
to do it honestly I need to hear what
you Milla Jamil has to say about this
because she's just like truly the
outspoken person for like body shamers
in the world and I need to get her take
on it but no-one's shaming you don't to
pay more it's no but there's something
here shameful about having to share it
there's something shameful about having
to wait on the earth spectrum it's like
no matter what your size like you're
always self-conscious about the number
I'm always so like and also like my
weight really fluctuates so I would need
like a good 15 pound range I also think
like a two weeks notice because I would
have to start dieting okay to get on the
plane but at least know what would be
crazy if they wanted to charge you like
if you have an overweight bag you get
charged
laughing you're overweight you've got
charge that's like that would be crazy
that's like when like an extra large
shirt is more money than a small that
doesn't happen now yes it does really
yes [ __ ] I ask treatment I think it
was when I was like looking at wedding
dresses I asked if bigger sizes are more
expensive because there's more material
and they were like no that's like so on
humane yeah but no they do I've seen it
before
oh I haven't not at like real stores but
like online I've seen it crazy crazy
anyways those are the five stories I
think they were very well rounded
usually were they were robust they were
robust they give you a lot to talk about
you know at your Seder at Easter Sunday
next year but I really I would love to
you know to hear you guys sparking
conversations and what you think about
human composting because I'm really I'm
about all of these stories Instagram
human composting and weighing Airlines
like I really see both sides of the coin
right like I get the metrics behind the
way but I'm not here for it you know
yeah but if it's saving lives and that
and the environment and it's saving fuel
except I think a little extra fuel can
go a long way when you have a divine
diversion add enough fuel to get to New
York right but the place we needed to go
was a little further right sure or what
about when you have to hover because you
can't land right like post Malone right
right well actually would have been
better if they had less fuel because
they were just up there burning fuel so
they could bind oh yeah you can also
drop fuel like in the ocean they weren't
they were above Teterboro oh they like
weren't yeah if they were having issues
god I got anyway so service stories that
you need to know this morning and
honestly you really needed to know this
one sometimes you don't need to know
like you really needed today you must
know that Scott Disick is getting with
his own show and that Taylor Swift has
pink hair and we have good vibes coming
our way on Friday you know what you
really need to know brand less do you
brand this i brand less I just got a
huge box of Brown less and it had so
many things but also for Theo and like
okay so Brown this ready you can get
anything on brown eyes organic virgin
coconut oil organic applesauce passive
pouches for us you can get kosher stuff
for Theo I can get all natural non-gmo
they love groundless loves people who
love to eat and that's why they love us
that's why their entire food assortment
is non-gmo made without synthetic
preservatives or flavors and they carry
a broad range of organic gluten-free and
vegan items you can literally search by
like what you're like you can do keto
Ben had a keto search in and they're
also launching a brown this baby
Collections where you can find clean
diapers clean baby care that's free of
the same 400-plus questionable
ingredients we've been from our other
clean beauty and personal care
collections plus non-gmo and organic
first foods bran this delivers
unbelievable quality at simple of fair
prices I'm like starting to get into
more organic but I feel like when I have
a kid I'm gonna be like I'm not letting
my kid have any of this crap like why am
i eating it you know Italy and they
talked about that on the episode that
we're posting today on patreon how
really like
the Tosun our sponsors has really made
me use more clean products and beauty
products food etc and I feel really good
about it like I feel like honestly this
show this you know what yesterday was
Earth Day and this is the eco-friendly
episode because it is our planet brand
this offers better options for the
things you care about besides price
organic Fairtrade non-gmo gluten-free
and vegan food items bakeware made from
professional-grade aluminized steel by a
family-owned company in the USA right
now our listeners can receive free
shipping on orders of forty eight
dollars or more at brand let's go to
brown less calm forward slash toast to
see our favorite and receive free
shipping on orders of forty eight
dollars or more
don't wait a second longer go to bran
list.com forward slash toasts to see our
favorites and receive free shipping on
orders of forty eight dollars or more
start enjoying high quality products you
deserve today videos probably reaping
the most benefits cuz I know many kids
he is probably reaping the most benefits
of Brenda's of this partnership brands
last precious gem of man ok Dan Turpin
paroles let's go oh ok super boring
episode but like really speed episode I
enjoyed all the wedding stuff
I loved Jax's response did you see my
side he said in my 7 years of television
I've never once complained about editing
but what they did to that scene I mean
that scene was horrible the scene was
horrible you could tell everyone's
reactions weren't paired up with what
was being said and then they teased the
scene so much in that in actuality they
only played like 1 minute of it which I
was glad for because I don't want to
know what Jack said I don't need to
watch fake television ok the guy in the
corner who was kept making like the
perfect facial reactions who is that I
don't think he was a member of the
family I think it was like one of Jax's
friends cuz he was being so funny oh I
don't even know and it's like they they
were using expressions of the other side
of the table being shocked and just
showing them like over Jack's speaking
but then when Jack's was speaking you
saw the guy next to him who was like
completely in agreement with ya so you
know that what he's saying isn't crazy
it was it it was definitely edited
really poorly and I'm glad he posted
that because I would have come on here
and been like what I thought you changed
like it was using and I said that when
Rachel Brian see I was like I was like
next week Jack's like looks really kind
of cringy and it wasn't matching up with
everything he's done this season so
thank you for the clarification
but at the end of the day Brittany's
brothers and dad are like so cute and
there looks like so southern
family so cute she's so cute and I'm
just loving her and her extra wedding
and like she has a maid of honor a
matron of honor and it's like I was so
the opposite kind of bride and I'm
loving finding out what this [ __ ] even
means
I thank you for letting me know what a
matron of honor is I didn't think it was
really interesting though that she shows
Katie technically it's her maid of honor
like I didn't even know that there are
clothes well I think she's equally close
with the girls but she already had a
maid of honor she's not gonna have to
but she's able to have a matron of honor
and Katie's the only married one that's
what it was so Kristen lost the job
because she wasn't married oh I thought
you I thought you have a maid of honor
but if they're married you just call him
a matron I'm pretty sure if you're able
to see I don't think you can have two
maid of honors but if you have a matron
and a maid it allows for you to have two
I'm including that's the vibe that I got
like it could have been Kristen by that
I had Brittany looked so good in every
single wedding dress like I was really
shook up I know and like I know I love
that she knows what she wants I love
that she knows who she is
yeah you know she doesn't she like
really embraces like the cheesy like
fairytale vibe and she doesn't like
she's just she's getting me so excited
for her and usually like TV weddings I'm
like I don't really now actually now
that I've been married I've like I care
more because now I know what everything
means yeah
but I'm just loving this storyline and
she's getting married in a castle like I
love her he's so cute and like
everything was so Disney I love that
forever rose in the jar and it's like a
person on my own so like to get that as
a gift like thank you so special so
special and they were all like just
really excited to be there Kristen was
being so funny actually like heard
thinking she was gonna be the maid of
honor like why I guess I think her and
Britney are really close and she is
everyone says she's incredible friend
Kristen yeah like she's there for
everyone all the time Rachel said it
here scheana said it last night on watch
what happens live we must talk about
sheen on watch about Oakley she with
coral she was with Carl their moms were
bartending behind the bar they were
flirting the entire time apparently they
got drinks earlier and they were going
out again that night and they 100%
hooked up last night for sure but they
pulled up before they hooked up before
she said and it was so funny because the
way that that came out they said
Stephens had it on net Oh
everyone in the world knows that because
of our show and then every time someone
was home watch out I'm sorry and II
would ask about it to us and then when
they were there last night they went
specifics scheana was like he rounded
third base and I think last night they
took it all the way because they were
like being so cute and lovey
well I'm really perplexed by what's
going on mashina I have to say it's
quite interesting
in terms of storylines that we're
getting they're so bored there's nothing
going on the season I'm actually
intrigued by this whole Adam thing
because I thought she was crazy he's
sheena in the beginning like pretending
that adam and adam was like i don't even
like her but now like adam totally likes
her totally likes her i'm i'm intrigued
and I'm also having a reaction while
watching whereas everything else I'm
like okay okay passive whether I'm
cringing I'm excited I'm sad for her I'm
like this is awkward I'm I'm feeling
some I mean that date was horrifying
horrified when they got on the bed to
like start filming a porno I was gonna
die she really needs to be the
Bachelorette like I know she has all the
chops yes but that would mean just to go
on first I don't know sometimes they're
always looking for the celebrity
bachelorettes like they always say
Chloe's gonna be it totally but they
anyways um the Adam of it all next week
they showed a promo for next week um
where she has that conversation with
Adam at the engagement party and they're
like screaming at each other and she
literally says to him like are you in
love with me and he was like no and she
was like answer a question he was like I
just it no like she she takes she gets
an engine she takes him I like she takes
everything too far you know yeah and
it's like I feel like she she like is
creating her own romantic comedy like
she get like think so that she's like in
the movie you know which kind of is
she's on a TV show you know it's like
she thinks that she's gonna bring this
guy in and Adams gonna just like chase
after her at her house yeah she like
thinks she's like the heroine in this
story yeah and it's like it's so painful
to watch sometimes but like she owns it
in last night like she was saying she
pass ordered through all of her scenes
last season with Rob because it was so
cringy right like and I feel like she
always owns that she's been cringy but
even while she's owning it she's being
cringy again so she's like but it's like
it's kind of how like you said Britney
like owns who she is completely unlike
her vision I'm like scheana like really
unsaid - like scheana is a basic ass
[ __ ] and like who is cringy and like
says like awkward things that make you
want to die but like that's who she is
at least she like owns that no she owns
it she doesn't try to change no matter
how many times someone says to her like
stop talking about Rob stop doing this
stop doing that she doesn't change his
she is and I just respect people like
that I couldn't agree more and in last I
don't want to happen time she was being
like the most Sheena Sheena
you really enjoyed it and like that's
what I want out of my TV character and I
think I've learned a while she was
trying so hard to change because like
The Witches of WeHo didn't like her like
that and her like being in authentically
someone else like was even worse like it
was even crazier so like she learned her
lesson that day and that was just like
me your south girl I totally I totally
agree and so she's also just great for
television and while everyone else is
being an adult she's still out here like
being single yeah like being young in
Hollywood even when she talked about
like I know Chargers Spurs and Lakers
cringe so I mean she was asked about on
the show and she was like no I never
hooked up with them like we're friends
she like got shot she was like it was
just a funny thing that I said what no
it's like if you're gonna say that like
onna take it all the way have some
conviction and run with it right
it was just I can't but whatever we must
talk about Ariana versus Lisa Vanderpump
oh my god I never thought I would be
selling Ariana side but like I'm so here
for it and that's what we've been saying
this whole time it's like there they are
technically equals now like they all are
reaping so many benefits from the show I
would dare say like Stassi is more
famous than Lisa Vanderpump like I was
watching stassi's Instagram stories this
weekend I've heard like on her book tour
like so many people showing up everybody
sure she's gonna be a New York Times
best seller like without a question she
might even be number one like that's how
many people showed up she did like 3,000
books like it's crazy
I thought about yeah I did so I was like
what read on them there and I don't even
think of Lisa Vanderpump wrote a book
like she could sell that many or that
many people would show up at a like its
equal now like we are on equal playing
the loving the playing field has been
leveled so the fact that Lisa Vanderpump
is constantly asserting herself as like
their boss as they're inferior to her
like it's frustrating because in reality
they're not know I am is like the first
one really picking up on it
Lisa has this restaurant it is called
Tom Tom like at some point you must
acknowledge them as a success and
instrumental to the success of this
restaurant and instrumental to your
success like let's do not forget like
you are cashing checks from Sur from
Vanderpump rules from Tom Tom and that
is all incumbent upon like them being
crazy and then taking trips and you
making a joke oh my god I so I so
understand what Ariana I was saying it's
like not only did you tell us to take
this trip we have to take this trip for
Vanderpump rules which is to show that
you produce and you make money off of
and you make money off of us going to
Mexico I mean Chris and vacation
episodes are the best episodes right so
it's like and now you're gonna like
throw it in the face in a public
interview saying like we're like
DeGeneres because we're going on the
trip thing you made a sake that makes
you money
so frustrating oh my god that made me so
mad I'm looking forward to Ariana
confronting her next week's Ariana's
very articulate and like it's annoying
when she's like not arguing on the side
that you want because she's always
making good points so I'm hoping that
like now that I'm on her side like she
will make some good points and I think
that Ariana I think that Lisa respects
Ariana to but I don't think she's gonna
respect what she's saying cuz all she
says obviously it was it was a joke
lighten up sweet I'm British
I can't I can't with the Jackson
accountability because she does that
with everything another rubber check
from Tom Schwartz even though you waited
over a year try gosh it that was so mean
and it's like first of all the second he
found out that his cash his check didn't
cash he took care of it look it's not
that he didn't have the money so he
handled it immediately and he didn't
like a cute kid she way like to make it
official like in fact they're making fun
of him for his small bills like that so
me and to me well actually I was curious
why the bills were so small so I was
glad she said something you know because
it's like why do you fifty thousand
dollars and five dollar bills but when
he said it was so that it looks like
even more otherwise I would have come on
the show and been like it was side other
business fake way cuz if it was all like
hundreds it would only be like a
thousand hundreds which isn't a lot like
it doesn't fill up a whole briefcase
right no I I didn't I was glad that she
asked that question but to keep harping
on like you just got fifty thousand
dollars cash don't bring up the check
again yeah okay also wait there was one
more thing uh I want to talk about James
I want to talk about Tuesday nights
because and the girls not wanting to do
it anymore
yeah it's like they did it to make a
point in that they were going to
continue doing it that would the point
isn't made just one time like the point
was like you don't need to have James in
here to make Tuesdays poppin but James
was consistently doing it every week
they did it wants to prove a point and
that never came back machine is working
answer now I don't know I don't think so
actually really well yeah the fact that
they like won't keep do it every week I
know that they're so busy and they're
not like just waiters and waitresses
anymore so it's different but like James
was being consistent and that's
consistency is everything it speaks more
than whatever [ __ ] is going on at
the restaurant like in the waiter
waitress like debacle right okay I have
to go pack up my apartment and movers
are coming so today today we're talking
tomorrow we're moving oh my god good
luck yeah thank you Godspeed are you
gonna be here tomorrow I'm not gonna be
here tomorrow okay I'll tell said it's
just to be they try to make it work but
it's like
I totally understand and I'm more than
happy to carry the burden that you carry
for me so often so I will take snitch or
unless someone else is in town but I
think snitch
maybe I'll do like a hotel or swifting 2
episode with Margot ok
echo chamber yeah let them work I'm not
really into like the negative vibes that
you're spewing when it comes to her
hardly negative no we raised some
interesting points play still I don't
want to hear they were like my overall
consensus is is positive yeah and she
can offer a little counseling to you and
tell the toasters so be here tomorrow
for me in snitch going live if you are
looking for some more episodes we've had
a premium maskk month on patreon that's
patreon.com slash morning toast we had
our Coachella vlog we had Jackie's
in-depth Q&A with Ben they had my very
in-depth Q&A with fashion of UT
lifestyle blogger Jackie a problem
she'll be posted today and then
yesterday we post our famous couples
throughout history summer saying was
their favorite episode yet and then the
final episode of the week is gonna be of
the month is gonna be our stagecoach log
which is gonna be so [ __ ] premium the
core for getting back together haven't
spoken to Lauren Elizabeth yet don't
know if she's coming but like still need
her to be there
right and I just I mention it every day
on the toes because I know she listens
so instead of like me being annoying
texting or like hey did you get your
tickets I just say it on the toast
because I know she'll hear it yeah this
manifest says nay exactly speaking into
existence exactly I'm thank you guys so
much for being here we will see you
tomorrow have an amazing day bye
you